I think yapping is one of the best
things to happen to communication. Allow
me to yap for a moment to explain. A
good friend of mine recently asked me
what my thoughts were on yap content.
>> Okay, guys. So, I literally cannot make
this up. I was just sitting there and he
walks in with a ice latte. Like, are you
actually serious right now?
>> And I was a little embarrassed. Maybe
it's my old millennial age, but I didn't
really know what yapping meant or what
it was. And so I did some research and I
understood that or came to understand
that yapping is essentially freestyle
talking on the internet at length stream
of consciousness. It's almost like your
audience has an inside view to your
brain working and you're verbalizing all
of the thoughts that you're having. And
I started to discover there's car yaps,
walking yaps, product lap yaps,
postdating
analyzing yaps. There's all sorts of
these yaps. And while it seems maybe
like an annoying trend or something that
we want to roll our eyes at, I'll
implore you to look a little bit deeper
because I actually think the ability to
yap, the ability to continue talking
continuously on camera is actually a
really good skill. And I think it will
serve whether it's content creators or
just in general people who want to work
on their marketing. I think it's a skill
to work on.
And what I like about it, going back to
the original point of why I think this
is good for communication, is that I
think that this signals authenticity.
So if we go way back into when
television was like the main form of
medium where most people got their
entertainment,
shows were really highly produced. If
you think about a talk show, the talk
show would be very short bite-sized
segments. The interviews they'd cram
into an hour, three guest interviews,
and there's no real ability to get into
any real substance in those chats. And
you think about there's probably makeup
artists who are making the guests and
the host look great. And there's all
sorts of graphics and B-roll and things
to capture and really make a polished
presentation, capture attention, create
a polished presentation, but it's it's
manufactured. And then you think about
how
there's been this move to consume things
like long- form content. So all of a
sudden people would listen to these 1
hour, 2 hour, three hour, 4 hour
podcasts
because they were interested in the
content and it didn't have all of that
polish. It felt more raw. It felt more
real. It felt more authentic.
And there's all this talk about the fact
that we have shorter attention spans,
but I actually think people will trade
attention
for authenticity.
People will trade attention for
authenticity.
And that's the idea with with streamers,
with anyone in this ability to have that
raw authentic feel like you're really
connecting with the person who is
creating the content, creating the
video. this video that I'm doing right
now, there's no edits. There's no cuts.
A lot of my videos, I will have a
thought and then I'll finish that
thought and then I'll look at my notes
and I'll look back. But I want this to
be a yap. And one thing I would say
beyond that is I think that that's going
to happen with AI written content. So
what I'm finding is I will get an email
and instantly I'm able to tell I think
that was that was written with chat GPT
or I see a social media post that whole
thing was written with chat GPT or any
form of AI. And sure you can use AI to
make things sound better, more
authentic, more human, but at the end of
the day there's still I don't even know
how to describe it. There's a structure,
there's a pattern, there's something
that instantly signals AI was behind
this type of written post. And I don't
know why for me, maybe it's just me, but
that's a bit off-putting. I don't love
it. And so I have this wild prediction
that I think people are going to start
to purposefully
make their content or their their
emails, their written communication
nonAI sounding. So, I think that there's
going to be this move, the pendulum
swung to so many people using AI to
write for them. I think that the
pendulum is going to swing the other way
where people will purposefully not even
look at the AI tools and just write
themselves in their own distinct style,
purposefully do things that go against
what AI does, like the M dashes and and
naming things in threes. Like, they're
going to go away from that to create
their own style. And I think that's
going to have a better connection
because of what we're seeing with the
authenticity. And so this is what I
think is the rise in yap content is that
it's authentic. People like the human
side, the authentic. So circling back to
the original point I made that yapping
is incredible.
It's a good step, a positive step for
communication, that's simply because
this is a move toward more authenticity.
And I always think that that's a
positive. more authentic, more human,
especially in this world we're living
in, is a good